good morning John today we're going to
be making cinnamon toast two different
ways first way
mmm the butter and the cinnamon and
sugar Korea's like frost on the top it's
hard and the bread is soggy underneath
there's good stuff this one's good this
is what we call the soggy technique
butter first then toaster now we're
going to try the crunchy technique
I'm not even gonna put this in my mouth
team soggy for life if you're confused
right now that's kind of the point is
opposed to something on tumblr about the
way that I make cinnamon toast and
people criticize me for it saying that
you should toast before you butter which
is ludicrous there was something of a
debate people die I mean people did die
in the world while we were having a
debate but not actually because of the
debate though I don't know teams Oggy
team crunchy there's a there's a lot of
animosity there I know I harbor some for
those team crunchies out there I don't
know what they're thinking it may be
that I'm projecting other stress onto
this situation I mean I don't know what
could possibly be it's a metaphor we're
a code in between your teeth but you
don't want it killing you you think that
poster is worth more or less now that
I've chewed on we just released the
agenda like what's happening at what
times during VidCon mm what is it 2014
right now I don't also discover during
this process that there are places where
toaster ovens don't exist it's like a
tiny oven where you just toast for
people who only have toasters I
understand why you do team crunchy it's
a limitation of your situation that's
fine you can't I'll ever broil in the
actual oven if you have one of those
it's just so much better it's so it's so
much better do a charity auction at
VidCon and I actually need to go paint
some anglerfish art for that auction so
painting art for the VidCon auction
problem is I don't know how to do that
turn on okay I only said that I do 204
housekeeping tank tops will be on sale
until Monday you're gonna get it tanked
up the pre-order only lasts on Monday
then we may bring them back we may not
depending on how they sell viana heard
about this or have been postponing your
ticket purchasing tour because awesome
with Hank green and the perfect
strangers and Harry and the Potters and
riffles Pony Club and Andrew Huang and
Rob Scallon
all amazing musicians we are going to
have a blast I hope that you're gonna be
there to have a blast with us there's a
link in the description if you want to
get tickets they're like 15 to 20
dollars oh no none of them funny when I
get really stressed out my like my
defense mechanisms is to get really
sleepy
how do avoid stress I know
unconsciousness that's great I would
totally rather that then just laying
there in bed
most stuff I just when I get stressed
out like a light bulb I go I like a
light bulb with a hole drilled in the
side of it they go out extra fast cuz
there's oxygen in the chamber needs to
be a vacuum so that the filament doesn't
burn yeah sometimes it's just better to
not better to not comment steam soggy
your team crunchy is that poster worth
more now or or less now thanks to
Michael Ron for help with this video
thanks to everybody for the help with
VidCon and John I'll see you on Tuesday